hey everyone welcome to the live stream
the first of the new year and that's the
theme here today what's going to happen
to us in the new year what are the
things that could cosmically go wrong
for us this year well we'll take a look
out into our solar system and identify
all the things that might end us yeah I
know it sounds kind of morbid and
fatalistic but you know our motto here
everybody dies we'll look at threats
from the Sun the moon asteroids and
later in the show my favorite what if
Earth were sucked into a black hole but
first to our closest neighbor
Luna the
moon where oh my
God is it a meteor
shower space
debris no it's something much much worse
our nearest neighbor is a full moon no
more the moon exploded and splintered
into millions of
fragments enormous lunar rocks are
hurling toward Earth could this wipe us
off the face of the
planet how could the moon explode in the
first
place and if we do survive how would
losing the moon change Life as We Know
It This is what if and here's what would
happen if the Moon EXP
exploded okay so how on Earth did the
moon blow up a blast mining operation
gone wrong a nuclear blast a collision
with a rogue
Planet whatever caused this catastrophe
you'd have to be packing some serious
Firepower to blow up the moon
guns lots of guns the largest nuclear
bomb ever built the SAR bomba had the
energy of over 57 million tons of
TNT think that's strong enough it's just
a drop in the ocean compared to the
amount of force you'd need to blow up
the moon you'd need the power of over
600 billion SAR bombas to destroy the
moon with anything less than that the
moon would just crack into pieces and
its gravity would pull it back together
again but if someone or or something
managed to explode the moon ah it would
spell bad news for
us the moon debris would scatter across
the solar system some into the abyss of
outer space and some headed straight for
Earth Earth's gravitational pull would
immediately start to attract the moon
rocks as the moon's remains start to
pick up speed
they would come crashing down into the
atmosphere luckily most of the smaller
debris would burn up before it reaches
us any larger pieces that got through
would be traveling much slower than a
similar sized asteroid the damage they'd
cause wouldn't amount to
much but is it just me or is it getting
a little hot in here the moon chunks
aren't causing much damage but the
endless barrage of debris on our
atmosphere would start to heat up the
Earth
the whole world would start to get
hotter and hotter eventually getting to
the point of incinerating all life talk
about a bad way to go oh and if you're
thinking about trying to evacuate Earth
you better do it as soon as possible the
moon debris combined with all the
satellites it would destroy in space
would make any trip out nearly
impossible but what if you did manage to
get out of Dodge or hunker down in the
deepest parts of the earth What would
life be like in the
aftermath well for some of us it
wouldn't get any cooler the moon helps
stabilize the Earth's actual tilt it's
what gives us
Seasons with a new Tilt some parts of
the earth could be constantly exposed to
the sun in the worst case the polar
regions could start rapidly melting
raising sea levels and drowning out part
of the
world as the debris settles the skies
could look a little different the
remaining Moon Rock might cluster around
the earth forming a giant ring like
Saturn but don't stop and stare too
long every once in a while some of the
debris could rain down onto the
Earth over billions of years the moon's
gravitational pull slowed down the
Earth's rotation giving us our 24 4our
days without the moon the Earth would
start to rotate faster and faster we'd
have shorter days and stronger
winds birds and insects would have a
tough time surviving the harsh winds not
only that ocean tides would start to die
down into tiny little waves the moon's
gravity helps create tides on Earth
bummed out that you can't rip some
gnarly waves anymore well dude there'll
be a much bigger problem it would wipe
out all of the sea creatures that rely
on the tides and ocean currents for
survival our whole world would be
literally flipped upside down the Earth
would burn up our days would be shorter
and the moon wouldn't be there to light
up the night
[Music]
[Applause]
sky what if the moon suddenly began
getting closer closer to Earth to the
point where it was on a collision course
with our planet would Earth survive the
crash or would a crash even happen would
the moon get torn up by Earth's gravity
what would this crumbled up moon look
like from
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if the Moon fell to
Earth the Moon is Earth's only natural
satellite and the largest object to
brighten our night sky it's the first
and only place beyond Earth where humans
have set foot
the mood's gravitational pull causes
tides on Earth tides that might have
been the encouragement for life in our
oceans to move on
land this pull also keeps Earth from
wobbling on its axis making our climate
relatively stable in short the moon
makes Earth a more livable place so what
if it suddenly sped up and started
driving in Earth's
Direction the moon's plan to destroy
Earth by bumping into it would break
into pieces the moment it reaches the RO
Li limit the moon itself would shatter
never making it to Earth's surface and
that's going to look very impressive but
wait what is this roach limit in
Celestial mechanics it's the point at
which the gravity holding a satellite
together is weaker than the tidal forces
trying to pull it apart in other words
the moon can only get as close as
18,47 km away from our planet before
Boom the tidal forces would tear it
apart all of the footprints and flags
we've left on the moon all of its aters
and valleys would scatter to form a
breathtaking ring of debris above
earth's equator 37,000 km in diameter
making Earth the second planet in the
solar system after Saturn to have this
striking ring of beauty the difference
being that our Rings wouldn't last long
the chunks of our former satellite the
moon would rain down on Earth it would
be as if hundreds of thousands of
asteroids were falling down on us and
wiping out entire cities in the
process once the moon began its
trajectory towards the planet it would
increase the tidal impact it has on us
by the time it hit the RO limit it would
be causing Tides as high as 7600 M our
world would be devastated by an army of
tsunamis 10 times a day but for a short
time hardcore Surfers would enjoy riding
some tasty
waves on the other hand this might be a
solution to global warming with the moon
coming closer and closer Earth's
rotation would speed up our days would
become shorter and shorter global
temperatures would go down and no one
would worry about climate change anymore
unless asteroids burn the Earth to a
crisp then there would be no one to
worry about
anything I really wouldn't worry about
it anyway in fact the Moon is drifting
away from us at a rate of 4 cm per year
so it's unlikely we'll get to see those
pretty saturn-like rings here on
Earth hey before we move on to the next
episode I want to tell you about an
amazing app I've been using to Kickstart
My New Year it's called greatness it's a
lifestyle and habit tracking app that
helps you build routines and improve
your physical and mental health I'm
using it to help me reach my New Year's
goals that I set out for 2024 it's been
great for me it's helped me build my
perfect morning routine and keeps me
more focused throughout the day the
other thing I love about this app is
that it has coaching and courses to help
you build the life you want and it takes
a gamified approach and it's gradual to
make sure you achieve your goals I
really want you to give greatness a shot
and lucky for you I've got a huge
discount to give out start the new year
off right and get 72% off a 12mon plan
by using the link in the description and
the first 100 people to use the code
what if 10 will get an extra 10% off
start your 2024 with
[Music]
greatness
tomorrow this is what if and here's what
would happen happen if the Sun exploded
tomorrow that star at the center of our
solar system that super hot ball of
plasma that gives us heat and energy and
amazing
complexions
you well it's a ticking Time Bomb the
sun is 4 and2 billion years old but it's
only expected to last about another 5
billion years after that the sun will
expand becoming a red
giant then it will shrink to become a
white dwarf a dying star cooling for the
next several billion years of course
we'll all be long gone before any of
that happens but still can you imagine
what it would be like to watch the sun
blow up before your very
eyes with a name like Supernova you'd
think that a solar explosion would be
the most magnificent fireworks show the
world has ever
seen But in reality he likely wouldn't
see
anything the sun is 150 million km away
from Earth and it takes 8 minutes for
light from the sun to reach us and while
that may seem super far away in
Supernova terms we don't stand a
chance for Earth to be completely safe
from a supernova we'd need to be at
least 50 to 100 light years
away but the good news is that if the
sun were to explode tomorrow the
resulting shock wave wouldn't be strong
enough to destroy the whole earth only
the side facing the sun would boil away
instantly the lucky other half would
experience a rise in temperature that
would be 15 times hotter than the sun's
current surface temperature and
permanent
Darkness and without the Sun's mass
keeping us in orbit Earth would likely
start floating off into space while its
remaining inhabitants desperately
struggle to stay
alive there is a chance that our planet
could lock into orbit around another
star that might provide the same light
and heat as our sun but by the time that
happened we'd all be long
gone if we knew in advance the day that
the sun would explode then we could buy
ourselves as many as 1,000 years of time
provided we had the resources to sustain
ourselves for that long and we could
just a few meters below the ground you
walk on the earth is maintaining a
temperature of about
17° so if we had enough time to prepare
civilization could continue to live by
moving underground into a huge network
of fortified
bunkers within a week after the
explosion the surface temperature on
Earth would drop to-
18° within a year temperatures would
plummet to about -
73° at this point the oceans would begin
to freeze from the top down within 1,000
years Earth's atmosphere would freeze
and collapse leaving anything left on
the surface exposed to Cosmic radiation
and meteor impacts hopefully by that
point we'd have found ourselves a new
home the good news is that if if the sun
were to explode and it will eventually
happen it wouldn't happen
overnight when the sun does die it will
be a long slow arduous process taking
place over billions of
years the sun will get hotter and
brighter and it will start to expand
during this process it will lose its
outer layers to the cosmos leading to
the creation of other stars and planets
in the same way that the violent burst
of the Big Bang created Earth
who knows maybe New Life Could form can
you imagine another Earth a new humanoid
species it's hard to predict how our
galaxy might look billions of years from
now and it's especially hard to imagine
our solar system without the great
Golden Anchor that keeps us all together
but one day in the very very distant
future the sun will expand and then it
will shrink Maybe leaving room for a new
star to take its place and if by some
miracle Humanity still exists at that
point where might we be living can you
imagine your descendants being born on a
space
[Music]
station What If instead of shining
brightly for another 5 billion years the
only star in our solar system turned
into a dark and cold Remnant a black
dwarf how long would the Earth last
without all the heat and light it gets
from the Sun and how would the sun going
dark change the
universe this is what if and here's what
would happen if our sun turned into a
black
dwarf all stars have an expiration date
they don't just Fade to Black though
stars like our sun don't have enough
Mass to become a neutron star they end
up expanding to red giants and then
shedding their outer layers until only
their core remains that's when they
become white dwarfs white dwarfs don't
have Fusion reactions fueling them up
they gradually cool down until one day
they become black dwarfs the thing is
there are no black dwarfs anywhere in
the
universe black dwarfs just haven't
formed yet you see white dwarfs may not
produce any energy but they still have
enough of it left to keep them shining
faintly for hundreds of billions of
years
given that the universe is only 13.8
billion years old even the oldest white
dwarfs are still glowing at temperatures
of a few thousand de Kelvin in the case
of our sun it will take another
quadrillion years for it to cool down
and become a black
dwarf that's 1 million million million
million years from now give or take a
few
Millions think humans will be around for
that long well let's switch it up what
if the sun burnt out tomorrow
I hope you have a good supply of
batteries on hand because the entire
solar system would be thrown into
darkness put on a few sweaters because
it would become much colder
too planetar speaking we're pretty
spoiled here on Earth with all the heat
and light provided by the sun we're able
to make a comfortable home on a rock
hurdling through space at 110,000
kmph it's easy to forget that we're just
another Speck in the universe but if the
sun stopped burning it would be a
immediately evident that we're just
floating in
space after the first week without the
sun's heat the Earth's surface
temperature would drop to 0° C after a
year it would go down even more dropping
to a freezing cold minus
100 that is if the sun turned into a
black dwarf instantly which is unlikely
even for our hypothetical
scenario realistically to become a black
dwarf the sun would have to go through
all stages of the Stellar life cycle
from the main sequence star it is now
the sun would expand into a red giant
fade out to a white dwarf State and only
then cool down to become a black dwarf
at the red giant stage it would bake the
Earth most likely swallowing it
completely along with Venus and
Mercury at least we wouldn't have to
worry about freezing to death once the
sun shrank to a black
dwarf what about the rest of the planets
the ones lucky enough to have evaded the
burning flames of the red giant well
they they' keep orbiting that remnant of
the Sun as if nothing had happened even
though the sun would shrink to the size
of the Earth its mass would stay the
same meaning that its gravitational pull
would remain unchanged in the grand
Scale of the Universe the death of the
sun wouldn't change anything either the
sun would be just another star to go
dark too small and insignificant to make
the universe even a tiny bit
darker pretty interesting you know along
those lines one of the questions I get
asked most is what if the Sun burnt out
tomorrow well that's actually a distant
second the question I get asked most is
and do you want fries with
that and the answer is invariably yeah
yeah I do actually now later on we'll
have a look at what would happen if
Earth was sucked into a black hole maybe
that's not going to happen in our
lifetime the nearest black hole is
thought to be over 1,500 light years
away so not going to swallow Us in
2024 but what about a thread a little
closer to
home what about that big yellow orb in
the
sky the sun's core is shrinking but as
its core shrinks the sun itself grows
larger and it will continue to grow
until one day it engulfs the
Earth how long can you
survive what will happen to the
oceans and will other planets be
affected this is what if and here's what
would happen if the sun swallowed the
Earth every 1 billion years the sun
becomes 10% hotter but here on what if
we're going to take billions of years
and condense the action into one
month get ready because we're going to
be moving really fast this
time instead of 1 billion years it would
only take 4 days for the sun to become
10%
hotter this means you'll see the Earth
engulfed by the sun in just 1 month that
is if you're still around to witness the
final
event
on day one you'd be blissfully unaware
of the tragedy about to befall Earth
maybe it's a little hotter but that's
just weather it
happens but by day four space agencies
across the globe would be sounding the
alarm
Bells by this time the sun would be
about 10% brighter and
hotter and while 10% doesn't sound like
a lot it will be the beginning of the
end for
us as the sun heats up more and more
water from Earth's surface will
evaporate into the atmosphere this will
increase the greenhouse gas effect
causing global temperatures to
Skyrocket all of a sudden it will become
very humid and very
hot but the sun's high energy light
would bombard the atmosphere splitting
those water molecules into hydrogen and
oxygen Earth will begin to lose its
water and you won't be able to escape
the lethal radiation on Earth's
surface if you want to survive you'll
have to go deep
underground but even under a protective
layer of Earth's soil you won't be safe
for
long
by day 16 the sun would be almost 40%
brighter our planet's oceans will boil
and there won't be any moisture left in
the
atmosphere the beautiful Lush Earth that
you grew up on will become a hot dry
Barren
rock around day 20 the sun would run out
of hydrogen so instead it will start to
burn Heat helium in its
core the sun is now a red giant star and
would expand rapidly while losing its
mass the sun's gravitational pull on
Earth would be weakened and our planet
would begin to drift away from the
expanding
Sun but not far
enough according to researchers klous
Peter schroer and Robert C Smith the
Earth would only have moved about
0.00002 astronomical
units an astronomical unit is the
distance between Earth and the
sun while Earth is moving away from the
encroaching Sun the red giant would grow
up to 1.2 astronomical units in
radius the sun would be larger than
Earth's
orbit it would swallow the planet
whole once it's inside the sun's
atmosphere Earth would collide with
particles of gas and spiral
inward and Earth wouldn't be the only
casualty of the expanding Sun Mercury
and Venus would be
vaporized the rings of Saturn would
melt Pluto would become much warmer and
if there is a liquid surface and a thick
atmosphere on this distant dwarf planet
it might even become inhabited
unfortunately 30 days doesn't give the
human race enough time to prepare for
such a catastrophic
[Music]
event the last time the world witnessed
a total solar eclipse was in 2017 and
its presence delighted enthusiastic
skywatchers this is absolutely
insane
but what if instead of a rare
phenomena a total solar eclipse became
an everyday
thing would you live in complete
darkness when does a total solar eclipse
occur and what would happen to the
moon this is what if and here's what
would happen if there were a permanent
solar eclipse
e a dragon devouring the Sun a giant
Puma demon a pair of skyw
wolves throughout history and across
cultures an eclipse has been interpreted
as a perplexing or fearful
event even the 2017 Total Eclipse raised
claims of impending apocalypse by
evangelist groups in the United
States but what if the next eclipse
didn't
end in this scenario we're talking about
a total solar eclipse which only happens
under very specific
circumstances first it has to be a new
moon
phase second the moon has to be at its
closest position to Earth also called
parag and third the moon has to be
directly in front of the sun it's like a
Sunset all the way around
me this rare planetary alignment would
suddenly become a normal
occurrence but don't worry you wouldn't
live in the moon's Shadow all the
time there are two parts to the moon's
Shadow the Umbra is the dark Center and
the pen Umbra is the outside edge where
only part of the sun is blocked by the
moon the Umbra has a diameter of 26 67
km which is about the size of the state
of West Virginia in the United
States because of the Earth's axis this
large Shadow would sweep across
different parts of the globe during
different
seasons the rest of the planet would be
in the
penumbra you'd still get sunlight just
not as much as you used to and life
would certainly be a little
dimmer existence on Earth is closely
tied to the the transition of day to
night a total solar eclipse would
disrupt this pattern and wreak havoc on
other natural
cycles under the Umbra the temperature
would drop about
5° even minimal fluctuations have
significant impact temperature changes
and lack of sunshine are not great for
agriculture so we would have to get
creative with growing our crops in this
new cycle of light and
dark we would also see an increase in
seasonal affective disorder or sad this
subtype of depression occurs during long
winter months in high latitudes with
lack of
sunshine you'd probably feel some of the
same hopelessness and loss of energy
under the moon's
Shadow though we'd have to come up with
a new diagnosis maybe Eclipse effective
disorder in a typical total solar
eclipse the Umbra moves across Ross the
globe from west to east lasting only
about 7 and 1/2
minutes this is because the moon rotates
around the earth making a static Eclipse
impossible so the only way we could see
a permanent solar eclipse is if the moon
stopped rotating around the
earth without its own trajectory the
moon wouldn't be able to resist the
gravitational pull from Earth and would
eventually destroy us
if that were the case then a total
eclipse really would be a doomsday
warning observing a total solar eclipse
is a once in a-lifetime
Opportunity let's hope it stays the
Marvel it
is life on Earth relies on the
predictable pattern of the Sun and the
Moon and we would be in big trouble if
our orderly Cosmos
changed permanent
Darkness sounds like life on YouTube
before what if came on the scene want
some Enlightenment well why not get
yourself a copy of the what if 100 100
of our most popular hypothetical
scenarios explained with science and
bound in a beautiful hard cover with a
forw written by friend of the show
theoretical physicist Dr Mito Kaku you
can pick one up at our merch store
that's shop.und.com and there's heaps of
other cool what if stuff there too
shirts hats beanies coffee mugs go on
start the year off right make Friends
and Influence People by wearing a what
if branded t-shirt like
me whoa watch your head some seriously
big asteroids are crashing into
Earth what kind of shapes and sizes do
they
have which ones would have the deadliest
impact and which one would be most
likely to hit us uh-oh get your bunker
ready this is what if and here's what
would happen if the largest asteroid hit
Earth okay let's get the terminology out
of the way I say asteroids but some of
the objects on our list are not
asteroids they're comets both asteroids
and comets are objects in our solar
system but
they aren't the same asteroids are rocky
leftovers from the early formation of
our planetary neighborhood and of the
over 1 million that we know of most
orbit the Sun in the asteroid belt
between Mars and
Jupiter on the other hand comets are
snowballs made of Frozen gases Rock and
dust they orbit the Sun and when they
get too close they start to melt M this
releases a giant cloud of dust and gas
that can be larger than most planets
with 3,000 known comets in the solar
system could a few be ready to turn the
earth into a giant cloud of dust
too chel yabin
meteorite let's start with a smaller
object that has already hit our planet
meet the chabin meteorite it exploded
over Russia in February of
2013 with a diameter of about 17 M was
relatively small but the impact was
huge the explosion had the energetic
equivalent of
500,000 tons of
TNT that's about 30 times as powerful as
the bomb that was dropped on Hiroshima
it injured 12200 people and caused
enormous property
damage pretty big effects from a little
extraterrestrial
visitor chicks
Lube moving on to something bigger will
go 65 million years into the
past the massive chicks Lube asteroid
was likely one of the forces that
resulted in the mass extinction of the
dinosaurs it was about 10 to 15 km wide
and its impact crater in Mexico's
Yucatan Peninsula measures 180 km wide
and 900 M deep wa when this asteroid
slammed into Earth it devastated
everything nearby the blast wave sent
enormous amounts of Rocky material into
the atmosphere and it caused tsunamis as
high as 1,500
M while all the soot didn't completely
block out the sun it reduced the amount
of sunlight reaching the surface of our
planet that seriously devastated plant
growth and had Rippling consequences on
the food chain eventually it caused
entire ecosystems to
collapse UA MUA
of all the objects that could collide
with us UA mua has one of the more
interesting
shapes this rocky cigar-shaped object is
about 400 m in length NASA classifies it
as a comet but it exhibits traits of an
asteroid too and it doesn't have an
attachment to any star system so we
don't know where in space it originates
from in
2017 it passed by the Earth at a
distance of 41 million
km now while we were safe from impact on
that occasion it could have resulted in
a lot of
Destruction if this Interstellar guest
crashed into Earth Darkness would cover
our planet and if the dust and debris
stayed in our atmosphere for a long time
it would kill many plants animals and
humans that depend on the
sun
benu benu is not only an asteroid you
should worry about it's the asteroid you
should worry about it has a 1 in 1700
chance of colliding with Earth in
September of the Year
2182 at only half a kilometer wide it's
relatively small but remember how sign
significant the chelan's impact was yeah
with that in mind you might be a little
nervous when it makes a close approach
to Earth every 6
years Shoemaker Levy
9 this next Comet doesn't have any
chance of hitting Earth that's because
it already collided with Jupiter in
1994 but you could imagine the
destruction this 1 and A2 a 2 km wide
comet would have caused on our home turf
it broke into 20 pieces as a result of
Jupiter's Gravity the collisions from
these fragments were so powerful that
they were similar to the detonations of
about 300 million atomic bombs plumes of
debris shot as high as 2,000 to 3,000 km
and the atmosphere heated to scorching
temp temperatures of 30,000 to 40,000
de you must be pretty relieved that
Shoemaker le9 never hit
us
series last but far from the least is an
asteroid so big it's technically
classified as a dwarf planet series is
the largest object in the asteroid belt
it makes up 25% of the belt's total mass
the radius of series is
km that makes it over 60 times larger
than our ancient friend
chicklo if series collided with Earth
there wouldn't just be
Devastation there would be no Earth the
size of series alone would block out the
Sun as it approached and then
the impact would remove 10 kilomet of
the Earth's
crust Hypersonic shock waves would
Ripple across the globe everything in
its path would be incinerated and
leveled nothing would stand a chance of
surviving our planet would essentially
turn into a glowing ball of fire and
melted
rock if by some miracle or secret
underground bunker you survived well you
wouldn't last long soot in the
atmosphere would result in something
like a nuclear
winter a giant asteroid is heading our
way but no it won't hit the Earth this
asteroid is about to slam into the moon
and crack it right in
half what would it be like to witness
this epic
Collision would the moon break cleaning
two
or would it shatter into a million
pieces and how could one of those pieces
wipe out life here on
Earth this is what if and here's what
would happen if an asteroid cracked the
moon in
half before getting into our scenario
let me tell you about the time long ago
when the moon almost exploded it was a
beautiful summer night in England in the
the year
1178 and 1 hour after Sunset people
witnessed a spectacular phenomenon a
giant flame appeared around the upper
part of that evening's crescent moon and
right before their eyes the moon
appeared to split in two before turning
black at least this is how the event was
recorded by the local
chronicler as you could probably guess
the moon didn't actually split in half
that night it's possible that what these
people saw was a large asteroid slamming
into it but an event like this would
have sent massive amounts of lunar
material toward Earth more likely what
they witnessed was a meteorite entering
the atmosphere and crossing their line
of sight directly in front of the moon
this would have given the illusion of it
splitting in two in a fiery fashion but
but who needs Illusions or questionable
historical accounts when we could
imagine what would really happen just
get ready to avoid Falling Moon
rocks the Moon is bombarded by hundreds
of asteroids and meteorites every year
and without an atmosphere like we enjoy
back on Earth these objects don't burn
up before impact so even a meteorite as
small as 25 cm across could have a big
big impact on the
moon in 2006 one approximately this size
slammed into it from Earth the impact
looked like a flash that lasted only
4/10 of a second but it created a crater
about 14 M long and 3 m deep taking
things up a notch a 40 cm meteoroid
slammed into the moon at a speed of
99,100
kmph this was such an Intense Collision
that it caused a flash as bright as some
of the stars in the night sky that means
when this happened in 2013 you could
look up and see the events unfolding
without a telescope for one whole second
at least the likeliest contender within
our solar system of doing some serious
damage to the Moon would be series it's
the largest object found in the belt
between Jupiter and Mars while it's
technically classified as a dwarf planet
it's still only about a quarter as large
as the moon but even that wouldn't be
enough to break the moon in two or at
least to knock it out of its orbit for
that you'd need an asteroid almost the
same size as the moon itself and if this
happened you'd know it right
away about 1.3 seconds after impact you
you'd see the Moon being torn apart
massive amounts of debris would be
hurdling toward Earth some of this
debris could be even larger than the
asteroid that caused the mass extinction
of the
dinosaurs but before you start picturing
the life on Earth wiped out scenario
things might not be as bad as you think
normally Earthbound asteroids travel at
speeds faster than 100 km/ second but
it's it would be different for the
chunks of the broken moon and the moon
destroying asteroid these would have
much lower speeds and with that much
less energetic impacts if you were lucky
the impact from even the most colossal
pieces of lunar debris would release
only 1% of the energy of a similar sized
asteroid adding to your luck you'd get
to witness a meteor shower of truly epic
proportions as smaller bits of De would
burn up in the
atmosphere and this epic Collision
wouldn't result in two split halves of
the moon now orbiting around Earth sadly
you'd have to kiss the moon goodbye it
would be shattered into a million pieces
but if it were to somehow break more or
less in two there would be a chance you
wouldn't even know at least not right
away that's because the asteroid could
have split the moon right between the
side that always faces earth and its
Dark Side you could still see the front
of the Moon beaming down on you
eventually the two halves could Escape
each other's gravity revealing two
hemispheres in the night sky and they'd
stay like that for a long time at least
until the effects of gravity pulling
each half from all sides shape them into
similar spheres but that would take
Millions if not billions of
years if the moon is blown to bits our
night sky would be permanently
transformed into a dazzling sea of stars
Venus would become the new brightest
object despite the fact that it's 14,000
times less bright than the moon once was
some of the more drastic consequences of
the Moon being destroyed would start to
make your life difficult
the Moon is responsible for the Earth's
23.4 de tilt on its axis without it this
tilt could become as much as
45° that would make our planet spin
nearly on its side and this would mean
the sun would no longer shine directly
over the equator instead it would beam
down closer to the North and South
Poles this would trigger some extreme
weather and could leave to ice ages that
occur on different parts of the planet
as often as every few thousand years and
the tides would never be the same again
Earth's powerful tides are caused by the
moon's gravitational pull on our oceans
the sun's gravitational pull on our sea
levels is only about half of what the
moon can pull off no longer having the
moon in our orbit would lower sea levels
and have a huge effect on ecosystem in
inter tidal zones tidal Wetlands species
would now have even more Fierce
competition for food and shelter this
could really endanger a lot of marine
life like sea turtles the rising and
falling of Tides is an extremely
important factor in giving their
offspring the best chance of
survival we just can't get away from
these everybody dies scenarios good luck
with that one but to be honest
comparably the Moon is just a pretty
small rock circling in our orbit it's
more likely that the asteroid would hit
us here on Earth well hopefully before
it does we'll get the chance to make
more cool videos for you and you can
help us by joining our patreon join the
whatif Explorers Club on patreon we'll
give you all the top secret behind the
scenes the extended director's Cuts
mind-blowing art epic merch discounts
and our endless love and gratitude you
even get the opportunity to pitch us
ideas for upcoming episodes now speaking
of upcoming episodes coming up we'll
show you what would happen if Earth got
sucked into a black hole but forget
black holes for a second what if Earth
got swallowed up by one of our neighbors
in the solar
system well there's one hungry gas giant
out there who has made a meal of a
planet before who knows if they'll do it
again
you start your day hearing wild news
Jupiter has just swallowed Saturn and it
doesn't stop there Jupiter is on its way
to swallow every planet in the solar
system how big would Jupiter
get what would you see from
Earth and would Jupiter get rings like
Saturn this is what if and here's what
would happen if Jupiter swallowed every
planet in the Solar
System Jupiter has swallowed a planet
before around 4 and A2 billion years ago
a protoplanet slammed into the young
Jupiter the protoplanet was 10 times
Earth's mass made of Rocky and icy
material Jupiter's core broke apart and
denser material mixed with hydrogen and
helium a few billion years later the
heavy material settled back into the
dense core that we see today now
swallowing a single planet is one thing
but could Jupiter eat up all
seven in this scenario you're going to
see the planets get swallowed from
largest to smallest although we're were
saving Earth for
last Jupiter's first victim would be
Saturn from Earth you could see these
gas giants as two bright stars and if
you were to look up at the night sky as
Jupiter swallows Saturn well all you'd
see is Jupiter getting super bright but
if you were closer to the action you'd
see complete
chaos Jupiter is only three times
heavier than Saturn so it would be
swallowing a planet that's almost its
size first their moons would Collide
creating massive amounts of debris some
Moon remnants would rain down on Jupiter
and some of the debris would float in
space as Jupiter was crashing into
Saturn Jupiter's surface temperature
would become hotter than the sun's outer
layer whatever remained of Saturn would
mix in with Jupiter's atmosphere they
would become
one now swallowing Saturn would increase
Jupiter's mass and gravity by
30% Jupiter would also sport prominent
new rings from the shattered moons next
it would envelop the two ice giants
Uranus and Neptune the 27 moons of
Uranus would collide with the rings of
Jupiter adding to the floating debris
Uranus has an icy core made of water
methane and ammonia but Neptune's inner
core is Rocky regardless both cores
would melt as the planets crashed into
Jupiter now Jupiter would be almost 40%
heavier and it would head towards its
first Rocky planetary
snacks the rocky planets Venus and Mars
wouldn't even make it to Jupiter's core
they'd burn up in Jupiter's atmosphere
as if they were were mere
asteroids then we'd see our last
planetary neighbor disappear inside this
bulked up Jupiter Mercury is even
smaller than Jupiter's largest moon
ganim so it would get ripped apart by
Jupiter's Rings adding to the Speedy
debris now only Earth and Jupiter would
be left and Earth would be in big
trouble but how would you go about
swallowing our planet you know even in
its normal State without swallowing six
planets Jupiter's gravitational force
affects Earth yeah every 405,000 years
the pull of Jupiter and Venus makes
Earth's orbit wobble it causes hotter
Summers colder Winters and more rainfall
in the tropics and now Jupiter's
gravitational pull would be over 40%
stronger
but Jupiter's pull would still be no
match for the sun's gravitational force
so Jupiter would have to come for Earth
just like it swallowed all the other
planets in our solar
system Jupiter doesn't have a hard
surface like the rocky planets you could
say Jupiter is a big dense ball of gas
its surface is defined as the point
where its atmospheric pressure is equal
to Earth's well so Earth simply pass
through uh no just like the rest of the
planets Earth and all life on it would
be toast first we'd be bombarded by
asteroids while passing through
Jupiter's rings I doubt anyone would
survive this but if they did they would
see the Earth igniting as it enters
Jupiter's atmosphere Jupiter is so
massive that even if it were to swallow
it seven planetary neighbors it wouldn't
even double in
size now what would happen if Jupiter
continued to
grow well even if Jupiter increased its
mass by
400% it would stay about the same size
but the extra mass would make Jupiter so
dense that it would start pulling in on
itself yeah it would get smaller instead
of larger and if Jupiter were to
increase its mass by
70,000 well it could trigger a fusion
reaction and light up like a
star when it comes to planets in our
solar systems habitable zone one world
is too close to the Sun another is too
far and Earth is just
right but maybe things would be
different if Venus and Mars simply
swapped
orbits what makes these planets
impossible to live on right
now what changes would they undergo when
they traded
places and why would you need Jupiter to
give these planets a chance at
supporting
life this is what if and here's what
would happen if Venus and Mars swapped
orbits our Solar System's habitable zone
otherwise known as the Goldilocks zone
is the distance from a star where liquid
water could exist on the surface of a
planet as long as conditions aren't too
hot or too cold life could be possible
just like on Earth but simply occupying
Prime real estate in the habitable zone
isn't a guarantee that a rocky planet is
actually habitable both Venus and Mars
orbit within this region too and yet no
life despite being of a similar size and
with roughly the same surface gravity as
Earth Venus is too hot to hold liquid
water and dense its atmosphere is 90
times denser than our own and the
surface temperature is a scorching
462 de
C on the other end of the goldilock Zone
Mars is also quite earthlike except way
colder drier and
dustier it's average surface temperature
is- 46° C and it has an atmosphere about
1% as thick as Earth's so if we swapped
things around would Venus and Mars
transform themselves into perfectly
livable
planets hey all I need to make my Planet
livable is a decent Grill and some Omaha
Steaks hey and as Father's Day is
approaching let me give you some advice
on what Dad wants it's steaks and right
now you can give him this mouthwatering
gift for just $99 it's a limited time
package that includes 16 of their
tastiest Entre I'm talking tender Smoky
bacon wrapped filet minol Gourmet jumbo
Franks and air chilled boneless chicken
breasts and to top it all off delicious
caramel apple tartlet
you getting hungry yet well stop buying
the same lame ties for Dad and give them
the experience they've been craving get
this deal now visit omaha.com and type
what if in the search bar to order the
dad's want Stakes package order now and
get eight of their new bigger Omaha
staks Burgers absolutely free and
remember everything is backed by their
100% money back guarantee now if you'll
excuse me I like my Stakes like I like
this new Mars just a little
red bringing the red planet into Venus's
orbit would put it at a distance of
approximately
108 million kilm from the Sun this would
bring it halfway closer to the Sun than
it was before being so much closer Mars
would get a significant boost in the
amount of sunlight it receives and that
alone can make the surface temperature
climb to a baly 32 2° C just like the
Earth's Tropics but without a thick
atmosphere or oceans all this new heat
wouldn't stay on the planet just like in
Earth's deserts Mars would see extreme
temperature differences between day and
night the thin Martian atmosphere would
make it difficult for water to stay
liquid with such a low surface pressure
water would boil at a lower temperature
evaporation would happen much
quicker looks like if you want to see
life flourish on Mars you'd have to take
a slightly more Hands-On approach but
first let's check out how Venus is doing
in its new neck of the
woods you'd Now find Venus located
228 million km away from the Sun that's
twice as far as it used to be and
naturally you'd think surely this
scorching Planet would be starting to
cool down well as it turns out the
planet's high surface temperatures have
a lot more to do with its thick
atmosphere than its overall closeness to
the sun Venus has a very high albo which
means that it reflects about 75% of the
incoming sunlight so it could be that
the planet's temperature remains more or
less just as hot as before even as the
upper parts of the atmosphere slowly
cool enough for the albo effect to
decrease that would mean that Venus
could now absorb a larger amount of
incoming sunlight so that temperature
wouldn't start to drop all that
much another setback on the road to
becoming a life-supporting planet would
be that Venus's atmosphere is mostly
comprised of carbon dioxide with small
amounts of nitrogen and clouds of
sulfuric acid what you still wouldn't
find nearly enough of is water the
concentration of water in Venus's
atmosphere is 100 times too low for even
the most resilient organisms back on
Earth to
survive but since you went through all
the effort of bringing both planets from
one end of the habitable zone to the
other why not take things a little
further you could try terraforming the
planets to make them a little more
livable one way you could increase
increase the surface pressure of Mars
would be to try releasing all the carbon
dioxide found in its soil and minerals
the only problem here is that the red
planet would need to reach temperatures
above 300°
C and despite this new location so close
to the Sun Mars wouldn't never get this
hot besides if you could release all of
that precious greenhouse gas it would
only amount to an atmospheric pressure
of about 10 to 14% of Earth's there
simply isn't enough carbon dioxide on
the red planet even if you had been
successful with that effort you'd still
be unable to breathe on Mars one option
for dealing with this would involve
bringing special microorganisms to the
planet that could convert the Hostile
Martian atmosphere into breathable
air this would be similar to what Earth
was like 2 and A2 billion years AO ago
back then cyanobacteria converted our
methane and ammoni atmosphere into the
oxygen-rich one you enjoy today but
ultimately this would be a big waste of
time and
resources you'd find that with Mars's
weak magnetic field it wouldn't be able
to hold on to any atmosphere you could
create that would be thanks to the power
of solar winds that would constantly
strip away
whatever atmosphere you'd manag to
generate and sitting in Venus's old
orbit solar winds would be almost five
times as dense as Mars is used to way
out on Venus the question of creating
conditions for life could come down to
whether you could manage to form an
ocean on the planet and that would
entail bombarding the atmosphere with
hydrogen as hydrogen is introduced to
the atmosphere it would react with the
carbon dioxide leading to the formation
of water introduce enough hydrogen and
you could eventually see Venus with 80%
of its surface covered in water for this
to work you'd need a lot of hydrogen so
much that you'd probably need to find a
way to harvest it from a gas giant like
Jupiter or Saturn or maybe one of their
moons yeah I'm not sure all this planet
moving and hydrogen bombarding was
really worth it you'd still be left with
only one Goldilocks Planet capable of
supporting
life could a black hole devour us all
one day there are millions of them out
there just waiting
and if we happened to make a black hole
accidentally well you better fasten your
seat belts things are really going to
suck
literally what would we see if we got
pulled into a black
hole could Earth orbit the sun and a
black
hole and would we survive
spaghettification
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Earth were sucked into a black
hole just 3,000 light years from Earth
is a black hole visible to the naked eye
thankfully we're a safe distance from
this Stellar black hole and many others
like it there are approximately 100
million of them out there in our galaxy
that we know
of they are are remnants of supern noi
which occur when stars 10 to 20 times
larger than our sun collapse in on
themselves Stellar black holes are
fairly common and are about 16 km in
diameter and then there's the much
larger
competition super massive black
holes these have a diameter roughly the
size of our solar system and a mass
greater than 1 Million Suns combined one
of them known as Sagittarius A is Right
smack dab in the middle of our
galaxy so how close would a black hole
need to be to be a danger to
us well technically a black hole the
size of a 1 mm pin could destroy us if
it was close enough to Earth due to its
incredibly dense Mass an extreme
gravitational pull our survival all
depends on whether we've surpassed the
event horizon or not you can think of
this as the black hole's point of no
return anything beyond this point would
have to travel faster than light to
escape yeah good luck with
that if Earth got close enough the side
nearest to the black hole would begin
stretching toward it our atmosphere
would start to be vacuumed up and then
huge chunks of the Earth would rip apart
and follow
soup if Earth managed to fall into the
orbit of the black hole we'd experience
tidal heating the strong uneven
gravitational pull on Earth would
continuously deform the planet this
would generate a tremendous amount of
internal friction heating the Earth's
core to disastrous levels
it would likely give rise to earthquakes
volcanoes and deadly tsunamis the
trifecta of
Doom eventually Earth would begin to
stretch in a process known as
spaghettification and not in the tasty
cheesy tomatoey way M let's say you were
a superhero and decided to fight the
black hole head first well your arms
would be closer than your feet causing
your body to stretch out vertically and
become more and more
compressed let's hope your superpower is
elasticity for an average sized Stellar
black hole spaghettification can occur
several 100 km away from the Event
Horizon but for a super massive black
hole physicists believe that this would
happen inside the Event Horizon due to
its size eventually no matter matter
what size it is anything entering a
black hole would be ripped into a string
of individual
atoms this would happen to anything that
crosses it people planets Stars you name
it unfortunately our whole solar system
would be doomed the careful balance of
the Sun and our many planets would
collapse which could send them crashing
into one another and to add insult to
injury our asteroid belt would get
sucked toward us about 200 of the 5
52,800 km across so if one hits us we'd
be dead before we would turn into
spaghetti frankly I'm not sure which
fate would be
worse all of the matter in our solar
system would join the accre disc around
the black hole as matter gets sucked
into the black hole it generates massive
amounts of radiation so even if we
somehow survived all the asteroids we'd
likely die from the
radiation Believe It or Not astronomers
have discovered rare circumbinary
planets that orbit two stars while this
may be a possibility with a black hole
and our sun the extreme tidal forces
would likely make our planet
uninhabitable and worse yet we might get
kicked out of orbit or swallowed by the
Sun or the black hole
eventually sorry but there's not an
outcome where we win
here but and this is a big butt maybe we
could find a way to protect ourselves in
some hyper reinforced space shuttle if
we somehow made it past the Event
Horizon we might be in for an even
stranger time physics as we know it
would change things like Gravity the
speed of light and even how atoms bind
and react maybe completely different the
truth is we don't know what would happen
we can't get any information out of a
black hole would we get pulled into
another dimension end up in a parallel
univ
or maybe we're already inside a black
hole you know last year we set a goal
for ourselves here at what if to get 10
million subscribers we're still a bit
short of that number hovering at just
under 8 million still respectable but if
you haven't already why not smash that
subscribe Button as the influencers say
say what do you think am I an
influencer I don't know I guess it
depends on whether or not I was able to
influence you to smash smash that
subscribe button did I well well thanks
yeah thank you and oh B fair enough mom
you do
you 50,000 years ago a space Rock
slammed into Earth and made a big boom
this meteorite was only about 50 m wide
but it weighed a whopping
300,000 tons when it smashed down into
the ground it flat and everything in the
vicinity it left a crater so lunar likee
that astronauts trained there before
landing on the moon yeah this is meteor
crater in Arizona and there have been
many impacts like this one in the long
history of
Earth if this meteorite were to slam
into New York today it would destroy
most of the city the impact would leave
a crater 1.3 km wide but the Fireball
would spread further everything within
1.7 km of the Impact Zone would burn
even on the outskirts of New York City
the windows would shatter and many
people would
perish it would take years to recover
from this
disaster but this is nowhere close to
the size of some of the largest asteroid
impacts Earth has
seen some of them were so gigantic that
if they smashed into us today they would
cause our
Extinction most of these asteroids
crashed when Earth was very young well
at least in planetary
years some 2.2 billion years ago a
pretty big asteroid made its way down to
Earth where Australia is now it left the
oldest confirmed crater on our
planet yababa crater doesn't look like
much to day but when it made its fatal
Landing it shook the planet quite a
lot yababa scarred the continent with a
crater 70 km wide it wiped out
everything in its way with a massive
shock wave scientists even think it
helped end the ice age that Earth was
going through by creating so much Vapor
that it changed the climate now imagine
this giant landing on Earth today if it
hit a Australia again and left a 70 km
crater there the fireball would spread
for 130 kmet in all
directions if it set a course for New
York it would decimate the entire city
even on the outskirts everything would
be on fire and you'd get third degree
burns but things could get so much worse
if an asteroid even larger than that hit
us like the one that crashed into Earth
1.8 billion years
ago this giant Comet punctured the
ground and shattered the
rock it left a crater
130 km wide where Canada is today we
call this crater Sudbury Basin and it's
one of the largest asteroid impacts
Earth has seen in its
history 1.8 billion years ago was a
violent time for our planet
the atmosphere was changing and
continents were on the Move shaking and
rupturing the land on their way massive
asteroid collisions were part of a
regular day back then now if this Comet
hit us today it would be a total
doomsday
scenario yeah if the Sudbury Basin
impactor landed on New York City today
well there wouldn't be in New York City
it would feel like being caught in an
earthquake that measured Ed an 11 on the
RoR scale everything would be shaking
from this immense and Loud shock wave
and everything 300 km from the impact
would instantly
ignite this is what the impact would
look like if it landed in
France yeah there's no chance you're
surviving this and we haven't even got
to the biggest impact yet it's time for
the dinosaur wiping
asteroid
65 million years ago an asteroid at
least 10 km wide smashed into Earth
where Mexico is now and violently ended
the era of giant
reptiles now imagine that same impact
today and well yeah it would be
incredibly violent the asteroid would
leave a crater 180 km wide and the
fireball well the fireball would burn
every everything in a 450 km radius if
this asteroid hit New York its effects
would spread as far as Canada and the
impact would be so painfully loud that
it would deafen
you you wouldn't just hear it you'd feel
violent vibrations in your entire body
and if this big Space Rock doubled down
on Mexico well much of the country would
see the same fate the region saw when
the dinosaurs died
enormous shock waves would cause
widespread destruction hundreds of
kilometers beyond the impact site and
just like 65 million years ago the
impact would cause a massive
tsunami okay it's bad really bad but
let's finally get to our number one
largest impact in
history Q the vfor asteroid the largest
almost the oldest and the most
terrifying space event on our planet's
record 2 billion years ago a gigantic
asteroid slammed into where South Africa
is today it obliterated everything it
likely changed the earth's climate and
it most definitely killed whatever lived
here before the
dinosaurs this same impact today would
bring enormous death and
destruction this deadly Space Rock would
obliterate everything for hundreds of
kilomet the crater from the impactor
would be as wide as 300 km and the
fireball would spread for 750 km in all
directions intense shock waves would
rush across the continent add to this
tsunamis earthquakes and wildfires and
this would be be a horrifying disaster
nothing in the area could survive
this but what's worse is that the
disaster wouldn't end there all the
debris dust and gases from the impact
would block the sunlight and pollute the
atmosphere we'd be like the dinosaurs
during their last days temperatures
would plummet the sudden climate change
would cause a massive Extinction
event Earth would become a pretty Barren
place and Humanity might not be able to
come back from
this deep under the Earth's surface
there's a scorching hot ball of metal
and scientists just discovered that
something very wrong is happening to
it did the Earth's inner core really
stop
spinning what apocalyptic events could
this trigger
and are we doomed to become as lifeless
as
Mars This is what if and here's what
would happen if the Earth's core stopped
spinning if you were to dig straight
down into our planet well you'd shovel
through four distinct layers on your way
to the center first there's the rocky
crust and that's followed by the hot
liquid mantle 29 100 km later you'd
reach Earth's outer core made up of
liquid iron and nickel combined with the
solid iron inner core the two core
layers of our planet are about the size
of Mars but unlike the red planet
they're scorching hot at 10,000 de C
well they're hotter than the surface of
the
Sun and there's also a lot of movement M
down there the motion of molten metal in
the outer core is what's responsible for
generating Earth's magnetic field
without that we wouldn't be able to hold
on to our atmosphere and we'd lose our
protection from dangerous space
radiation and the inner core of our
planet is moving too but new research
suggests that it's slowing down to
rotate more in sync with the rest of the
planet but slowing down isn't dramatic
enough let's see what happens when both
layers of the core stop moving
completely if only the hot solid inner
core inside the outer core stopped
moving well you wouldn't need to worry
about the apocalypse just yet the
slowing down of the inner core would
mostly impact the speed at which Earth
spins it could slow our rotation down
enough that our days would become longer
and over time this could degrade our
magnetic
field yeah that would be bad news but
not nearly as bad as what would happen
if the syrupy outer core stopped
spinning too without that layer's
rotation well you'd have to kiss our
magnetic field goodbye and this would
put Earth on a course to end up looking
a lot like
Mars 4.2 billion years years ago Mars
could have been warm enough to have
Oceans Where life might have
thrived but when the red planet's core
froze in place its once strong magnetic
field
weakened as the Martian magnetic field
degraded its atmosphere was chipped Away
by ferocious solar winds slamming into
the planet at speeds of several hundred
kilomet per second
that's when the planetet transformed
into the dry lifeless desert you know
today but back to Earth before it
completely turned into a desert Planet
well things would get a little shaky if
the core was to suddenly stop rotating
the tectonic plates would violently slam
into each other it would be a lot like
when your bus driver hits the brakes
hard and you go flying into the other
bus riders this sudden Collision of
tectonic plates would cause massive
earthquakes along the plate boundaries
all around the world these Quakes would
destroy buildings roads and bridges
electricity phone lines and Water
Systems would be
severed ultimately millions of lives
would be lost and millions more people
would be
displaced now as devastating as these
earthquakes would be the damage would
just be getting started with The
Disappearance of our magnetic field
you'd be exposed to dangerous Cosmic
radiation that would bombard the surface
of our planet these high energy
particles from the Sun would interact
with the abundance of nitrogen and
oxygen in our atmosphere and this would
destroy our protective ozone layer
allowing more UV radiation to reach the
surface combining these solar rays and
UV radiation would be enormously harmful
to all life on Earth it would damage
your DNA leading to mutations and
cancer and the halting of the core would
also make navigating the globe more
difficult yeah I hope you have a good
trail map for your next camping trip
because compasses would be totally
useless all kinds of migratory animals
would lose their way too birds flying
south would get lost and freeze to death
while sea turtles would never find their
way back to the beaches that they lay
their eggs on the earthquakes caused by
the core suddenly stopping would have
already done significant damage to the
power infrastructure around the world
but the lack of a magnetic field would
continue disrupting things even more the
solar radi ation bombarding the surface
would damage all kinds of electronic
devices and would threaten our power
grids you would end up losing power more
often maybe even
permanently but in reality you don't
have to worry about a catastrophe like
this this study which implied that the
core has stopped and we're all
doomed was a a little
overhyped scientists didn't even talk
about the outer core no they just meant
the inner core which rotates
independently from the rest of the
planet it doesn't stop or reverse its
rotation it just moves slower and faster
like it's done for the billions of years
of our planet's
existence okay that's it that's the show
thanks for joining us on this terrifying
trip through through several scary
scenarios hope you liked it hope you
learned something Let's cross our
fingers that none of these events come
true this year or any year here's
wishing you good health and prosperity
in the months ahead and as always we'll
be back soon with another what
if
hey everyone welcome to the live stream
the first of the new year and that's the
theme here today what's going to happen
to us in the new year what are the
things that could cosmically go wrong
for us this year well we'll take a look
out into our solar system